okay good afternoon everyone today we
are going to assemble some viruses this
is the last of this basic part of the
course of replication of viruses from
now we move on to how viruses cause
disease so I hope you understand
everything we've gone through so far if
not ask questions okay because if you
don't understand what we've done the
second half of the course will be harder
putting together viruses there are a
certain assembly of viruses occurs in a
very ordered fashion if it didn't things
would be a mess with viruses so most
viruses undergo a common set of assembly
reactions which are shown here remember
you have to make the viral proteins
first and you assemble them into
structural units that can be one or it
can be several proteins you have to
assemble the shell that happens
spontaneously you have to put the genome
in the shell talk a little bit about how
that happens for some viruses an
envelope is acquired but not for all
that's why it's in blue this is the
virus has to be released from the host
cell and some viruses actually mature
after they get out of the host cell
we'll talk of an example of that today
now the way viruses look can tell you a
lot about how its formed you can you
should be able to look at most of these
viruses and tell me how its formed that
would be a good question don't you think
I could give you a picture of a virus
and you say tell me how this matures so
you could look at an envelope virus and
say it has to acquire its envelope by
budding in some way and we'll talk about
that today these guys here acosta Hedra
viruses don't have to bud through
anything so you can learn a lot just by
looking at the structure of the virus
you can tell how its formed and even how
it gets into a south because with
envelopes you know we've talked about
how fusion has to occur between the
membranes
and so forth the structure of a virus
has important consequences for the kinds
of infections that can take place as
well it's not just a matter of looking
at these nice structures for example
here is a tale of two popcorn of viruses
polio virus and rhinovirus are both
picornaviruses they look very similar
the genomes are very similar the
particles or icosahedral particles look
very similar yet they have totally
different pathogenesis polio virus
infects by the alimentary tract that
goes through your stomach therefore it's
resistant to low pH to alkaline pH two
enzymes that it encounters in this
passageway a very structurally similar
virus rhinovirus cannot infect the same
way it cannot go through the gut it's
destroyed if you have a common cold and
you swallow some of the viruses you're
producing and you do that from time to
time they will be completely inactivated
as they pass through your stomach you
can only in these viruses can only
infect the respiratory tract work things
are a little easier for a virus so this
despite that the structures are exactly
the same so the details obviously can
determine all of this and remember all
viruses all very ons are metastable
can't emphasize that enough they have to
survive in the environment but they have
to come apart upon infection so they are
built in a way that allows disassembly
this is a very interesting point because
as you will see the assembly pathways
that lead to viruses virion particles
are not reversible for the most part so
when you assemble and that what that is
what makes the quality control of
assembly work that it's a non-reversible
pathway yet when the virus is made and
it encounters some condition it can come
apart again so obviously those
conditions a low pH and an endosome
cannot be encountered during assembly
the virus assembly also depends on the
host cell of course as has almost every
other aspect of I
Earth's replication there are cell
proteins that help to fold individual
proteins viral proteins so that they
fold properly and glycosylation plays a
role in that transport systems move very
on components around the cell to the
sites of assembly remember the same way
that microtubules and other transport
pathways brought viruses in the same
systems are going to bring proteins to
where they need to go for assembly
things don't defuse remember in the cell
the secretory pathway will move membrane
proteins from the ER to the plasma
membrane and the nuclear import and
export machinery will move proteins in
and out of the nucleus and you'll see
for some viruses they're quite a series
of complex import and export steps that
have to occur in order to get proper
assembly so all of these steps depend on
cell processes now key a key aspect of
assembly is that nothing happens fast
and dilute solutions things always have
to be concentrated and that's what
viruses do in cells they maintain their
crucial components highly concentrated
so that they assemble quickly they are
often visible in the microscope as a
consequence you can often look at an
infected cell and you can see
concentrations of viral assembly
products which for different viruses are
characteristic of in fact we call these
factories or inclusions internal
membranes can also be used of the cell
to concentrate proteins we talked about
how polio virus during RNA synthesis
concentrates the replication machinery
on a vesicle that's a form of
concentration probably assembly also
occurs on the same vesicles as well here
is an example of a inclusion body this
is a picture of a cell it's infected
with a virus and these this is these are
the assembly these are the inclusion
bodies here these darker staining bodies
around the nucleus so there's one up
there there there
there anyone know what virus this is you
if you were a pathologist you could look
at this and say it's probably this virus
I wouldn't expect any of you to know
that I can give you a hint though you
get this by being bitten by a dog Greg
sorry I rhabdo virus rabies virus so
this is a rabies virus in fact itself
and these are called negri bodies by the
italian pathologist who discovered them
many years ago and if you see those in
your cells then you're in big trouble
because that looks doesn't look like any
other virus infection negri bodies and
every virus has its own characteristic
assembly pattern so how do viruses get
concentrated to do this they can be
produced in a compartment of a cell
which we call a factory or some
localized site they can be
protein-protein interactions that are
involved that help concentrate different
parts of the assembly pathway so you can
make one subunit in a second and they
can interact in some way and concentrate
them in a particular part of the cell
also membranes can function to help
concentrate components so when things
are associated with membranes they
become concentrated so these are just a
few of the ways that we achieve this
state that pushes the reactions forward
not dilute assembly also has to occur in
the right place in the cell the
different steps of assembly and this
haps this helps viruses be produced it
increases the rate of reactions as we've
just said and it restricts side
reactions so instead of having the
proteins diffuse throughout the cell
they're concentrated in one place the
likelihood that they're going to under
grow the right reactions is increased
that's what we mean by restricting side
reaction we increase the specificity and
the efficiency of assembly now remember
just less we were talking about in virus
entry moving in a cell is not a trivial
problem you cannot just diffuse you have
to be moved by active processes
so again remember the cell is a crowded
place here's a snapshot of the cytoplasm
with ribosomes and microtubules and all
sorts of molecules floating around to
move distances like from the plasma
membrane to the sites of replication
requires transport systems such as the
microtubule energy dependent motor
proteins ons on cytoskeletal tracks that
not only functions when viruses come in
the cell but it also functions to get
viruses outside of the cell as well
viral proteins also have addresses built
into their structures that target them
to the right places and we have membrane
proteins for example that go to the
right membranes their addresses and the
proteins that specify this signal
sequences that the n-terminus that
directs the protein to the endoplasmic
reticulum fatty acid modifications as
you'll see in some proteins direct them
to membranes membrane proteins stay
there because they have retention
signals ER retention signals keep
proteins in the ER rather than going
somewhere else nuclear proteins have
nuclear localization sequences that
target them to the nucleus viral mrnas
or rather nuclear protein complexes that
are made in the nucleus go out into the
cytoplasm because they have export
signals associated with so this is what
we mean by addresses built into the
structure and it capsids in protein
complexes have directed motion as we've
said they don't just diffuse all around
the cell they're going to a very
specific place and that's because they
move on tracks microtubules and
intermediate filaments are the tracks
that these proteins and assemblies move
on and these are the motor proteins that
move them along so you should send
something here that is obvious and that
none of this is virus-specific all of
this address information exists in the
cell already viruses haven't invented
anything they're just co-opting systems
for directing their proteins to the
right place here's an example of
localization of viral proteins to the
nucleus many viruses need to be there
not only to replicate their DNA
also to assemble virus particles we
talked about the influenza virus
requirement for the nucleus which is
unusual for an RNA virus the rnp that is
produced has to be translated the
protein components have to be produced
in the cytoplasm so as you know the
ribosomes and the translation machinery
cytoplasmic so if ain't protein needs to
go into the nucleus it has to be
important this example is the influenza
virus nucleoprotein which is one of the
protein that coats the RNA genome the
RNA genome is produced in the nucleus
this NP has to go into the nucleus to
coat it the NP has on it an import
signal so that it can get into the
nucleus here is an adenovirus protein
the hex on which is one of the
structural components of the capsid the
DNA of this virus replicates in the
nucleus so these structural components
are imported into the nucleus and
coalesce around the DNA same thing with
polyomavirus one of the small
double-stranded DNA viruses the
structural proteins again are made in
the cytoplasm and imported into the
nucleus all right these are all but
needs our old directionality is that are
established because the viral genomes
replicate in the nucleus how about if
you want a viral protein to be on the
plasma membrane many viruses put them
there so that they as you will see they
can bud form particles by budding so you
to do that you need to utilize the
transport pathway of the cell the
proteins have to have a signal sequence
that targets them to the endoplasmic
reticulum they are produced in the lumen
they then move to the plasma membrane
via the Golgi stacks and on the way
there glycosylated and modified in
various ways and eventually they are
delivered to the cell surface now by
vesicles that bud off the Golgi and are
transported on tracks just like other
movements in the cell up to the surface
so here are some viral glycoproteins
coalescing at the cell surface getting
ready to receive nucleic acids as well
see so it's another example of the
addresses that are important in
targeting proteins to the
place so let's talk about a couple of
different strategies for making viruses
and one of the key concepts is that
we're going to make sub-assemblies we're
not going to take 20 proteins and have
them all come together at once we're
going to have a few proteins make one
sub assembly and if you make another and
then the sub assemblies will come
together and each step is going to be
irreversible so we're going to look at
three strategies here and the first one
is assembly from individual protein
molecules an example here is simian
virus 40 of poly a polynomial virus and
this is one of our double-stranded DNA
viruses relatively small Tyrion's the
capsid is made up of vp1 vp2 and vp3
these proteins are translated from
individual messenger RNAs in the
cytoplasm and they fold and then
assemble to form the sv40 pentamer so
the pentamer has mostly vp1 a little bit
of vp 2 and v p 3 so this is an example
of a sub assembly then these are going
to go on in form intact fury ons so you
make a lot of sub assemblies and make
the very end the key here these are made
from individual protein molecules
another example is add no virus one of
these larger DNA viruses with different
proteins in the shell serving different
functions and remember one of those
proteins is the fiber that sticks out
from each five fold axis of symmetry so
we're looking at the Assembly of the
fiber and the the base that it's
attached to the pent on so the protein
for is produced by translation of viral
mrna is this this becomes a trimer and
folds to form the fiber the base is a
pentamer of protein 3 these are focus
again translated individually they fold
into the structure needed and then five
of these form the pent on base so then
those two come together to form the pent
on which consists of the fiber and the
pent on base so again an example of a
sub-assembly these eventually we'll go
into constructing new virions and
they're just made simply by making
individual proteins
yeah so these proteins have all the
information in their structure to be
able to fold into the right
configuration and also to associate with
other proteins as well some cases there
are there are chaperone proteins in the
cell that help the folding but most the
information is in the amino acid
sequence to dictate how this works yeah
and here's the third strata another
strategy from making sorry to strategies
for making sub-assembly panel B assembly
from a poly protein precursor a number
of viruses do this including polio and
other pakorn of viruses the capsid
protein is translated as a long
precursor the capsid proteins RVP one
two three and four these are made as a
precursor it then folds by itself and
then again the the information for this
folding is built into the amino acid
sequence so here we have p1 made it
folds and then these loops that join the
capsid protein together clipped by a
viral protease and that gives you the
mature structural unit here which
happens to sediment at 5s and that is a
sub assembly that will go on to be
joined with others of its same kind to
make the capsid the difference here is
that the protein is produced as a poly
protein not individual proteins as we
saw in the previous example now
sometimes as I said you need chaperones
to help the folding run properly there's
even some evidence may be for for polio
that you need a chaperone to help this
fold correctly this probably protein
precursor but here's a well-described
example of the Assembly of a add no
virus hex on which is a trimer of
protein to hex on is one of the main
building blocks of the capsid the exons
and the penton's build the caps of the
penton's are at the five fold axes and
the hexans are elsewhere protein too is
made from a single mRNA it assumes a
confirmation and then to try memorize it
requires
the chaperone which is another viral
protein called l4 so this helps the
three monomers associate with one
another they can't do it on their own so
the monomers can fold into into this
monomer the polypeptide chains can fold
into a monomer but they can't trimer
eyes without this viral chaperone and
sometimes cellular proteins serve
chaperone functions as well okay so
those are examples of making a
sub-assembly let's take one of these
examples all the way through from the
beginning to the end and see how virus
particles are made so this is the
example the example use here is polio
virus these are of course icosahedron
virions we're looking at the entire
infectious cycle here the
receptor-binding internalization of the
RNA into the cell translation into
proteins remember this is a poly protein
so it's cleaved by viral proteinases the
very n terminus of the poly protein
called p1 encodes the four capsid
proteins VP 1 through 4 we just saw on a
previous slide how those associate how
those fold and our cleave to form this
5s structural unit five of these then
come together to make what we call Penta
murs so they happen to sediment at 14 s
but the real important point here is
that there are five subunits that make a
pentamer you can see those here nicely
and eventually those penta murs will
come together to form the intact caps at
12 Penta murs will come together to make
the capsid so that's an example you
start with the 5s the sub-assembly you
make it pentamer which is another kind
of a sub assembly and from the pen
tomers you make viruses each of these
assembly steps is irreversible so you
make good 5s units you make a good
pentamer that's it you can't take the
pentamer and get 5s subunits back out of
it and the same way is if you make the
capsid from the Panther MERS you can't
reverse that now an interesting question
is how the RNA gets into this because
I'm telling you that these pentamer is
for mac apps
and what we think is that the RNA
actually binds the pentamer and that
helps it in caps a day but that's a
little bit speculative so the packaging
of the genome will talk more about
packaging a bit later isn't really
worked out what i want to show you this
as an example of is a sequential
stepwise capsid assembly using sub
assemblies okay here's another example
of this assembly line concept taken to a
greater extreme because this is a more
complex virus this is a bacteriophage
and see here's the end product this is a
tail the bacteriophage these are
characterized by having a head which is
a capsid + icosahedron captured the
nucleic acid is in there and then it has
a neck and some tail fibers and the DNA
is injected through the base plate here
the phage lands on the bacteria
interacts with receptors and then the
DNA this there's a structure on the
plate here that actually pokes a hole in
the bacterial wall and then the DNA is
injected through these are made as
components so the tail is made
separately this could be Ford Motor
Company the tail is made separately
these are all the proteins that go into
making the base plate and then you make
the shaft and then you put these rings
around it and there you go that's that's
one person's job to make the tail
assembly and then the head same way you
whistle you assemble an icosahedral
protein excuse me an icosahedron shell
and you're adding additional proteins at
each step that's then attached to the
neck or the tail and then finally you
make the tail fibers and put those on so
three different sub assemblies with
complex steps and the key here too is
also that all these are irreversible and
that assures that they flow forward if
you make the proper assembly if you make
the right base plate it flows through
the pathway if it's not correct if its
aberrant in some way it doesn't know
long and no longer goes through the
pathway it's discarded and recycled so
that's the assembly line concept with
sub assemblies that's why I say you
don't make
there are 50 or 60 proteins here you
don't make them all and they all come
together to make a virus particle that's
not how it works they're done in very
precise steps so assembly line
mechanisms make sure you make the virus
and the right sequence of events you
make discrete structures and quality
control is the key you can't make this
unless you have this so to make sure
that every step of the way works let's
look at how another kind of virus is
assembled this one in the nucleus this
is a herpes virus and as you know this
is a virus with a rather large d a
double-stranded DNA genome that genome
replicates in the nucleus so here's
here's the nucleus right here most of
the slide users are nuclear pore complex
as the cytoplasm is out here so the
genome replicates in the nucleus and
that's where the particles are going to
be assembled so the particles of course
are made of proteins of different sorts
those are translated in the cytoplasm
have to be imported into the nucleus and
so here we're showing the import of a
variety of components that are important
for assembly of this herpes virus we
have VP 26 we have some vp5 penta MERS
we have some other proteins here as well
and then we have our portal if you
remember there's one portal / virion
through which the DNA goes in and out
now these are very large virions and in
fact they're very difficult to make as
empty capsids so what is done is that a
scaffold is built first and then the
capsid is built around you notice
scaffold is on a building right it's
those metal things they put on the
outside so that they can then bring the
building up same idea except here the
scaffold is interior it's really clever
you can't just build the shallow would
fall apart so you build a protein
scaffold you build the caps it around at
all these capsid proteins are then
assembled this is an icosahedral shell
and then inside there is also a viral
protease which then when the whole thing
is complete digests away
scaffold so that's what we see here VP
24 protease digests away the scaffold so
now it's empty here but it's stable
because it's all been built and then we
can pump the DNA n so the DNA goes in
through a portal and there you see the
DNA all coiled inside the capsid so
these scaffolding proteins established
transient structures they're not there
permanently and the viral protease
packaged in them become activated to get
rid of the scaffold at one point this of
course is a nucleocapsid it's eventually
going to be envelope going to acquire
several envelopes on its way out of the
cell so that's an example again of a
virus that's assembled in the nucleus
here's another example this is ad no
virus same idea the virus has to
assemble in the nucleus that's where the
viral DNA replicates it's just a
slightly different sequence of events
there's no scaffolding necessary for
this virus it's slightly smaller than
the herpes viruses but again the DNA is
in the nucleus it's this blue
double-stranded chain here you have to
import all the proteins that you need to
build vearios you need hex on trimers
you need the pant on which we talked
about in other very on proteins as well
all of these are produced in the
cytoplasm they're imported and what you
do four add no viruses you build an
empty capsid and then the DNA gets
imported into it and that produces
eventually the mature virion there a
variety of steps here which aren't
important for you to to know at all the
fact here is that you make an empty
capsid without a scaffold and then you
import the DNA the DNA by the way is
complex with a variety of proteins which
are these guys here you could see them
complex to the DNA eventually you get
the mature virion I like to show this
slide because I like the young virion we
used to have a colleague named Seamus
young and guess what virus he worked on
had no virus but he didn't name this
particle right I think someone named it
in his honor now it has nothing to do
with him
but I always think of it when I talk
about it so a lot of these assembly
steps are they occur on their own the
information for assembly is built into
the amino acid sequence but some of them
need to need help they need chaperones
so we have self an example of self
assembly is HIV capsid proteins if you
express the capsid protein precursor in
cells that would be the gag protein
those foreign particles you don't need
anything else just Express that protein
you will make empty particles if you
express the influenza hemagglutinin just
by itself in cells that will cause
budding in the formation of virus like
particles so two examples of how
particles can be made on their own they
also that hepatitis b surface antigen if
you express just by itself in the cells
it will make particles examples of
assisted assembly these are viruses that
can't assemble on their own proteins and
nucleic acid genomes are needed as
scaffolds or chaperones so we saw an
example of that with herpes virus when
you needed a scaffold in the interior so
you can't make a particle just by
expressing the capsid proteins you need
to have the scaffolds as well and add no
virus needs the genome let's look now at
the budding of viruses this is influenza
virus maturation and this is a process
of called concerted assembly so in all
the examples we've looked at so far
there's been a sequence of events that
occur you make a sub assembly and other
sub assembly and so forth so it's a
sequential process here everything comes
together at once you make sub assemblies
and then at one point they all come to
form a particle so an influenza virus of
course is envelope and as membrane
glycoproteins so those have to be placed
in the plasma membrane via the secretory
pathway so ribosomes translate the mrnas
encoding the hemagglutinin and the
neuraminidase on the ER and these are
transported up to the plasma membrane
and those are in bed
the membrane right here underneath it is
the viral genome which you remember is
in eight pieces sony one of the pieces
is shown here for clarity this viral RNA
is made in the nucleus so remember from
the negative strand genome we make
messenger RNAs these go out into the
cytoplasm to make proteins we replicate
that negative strand through a positive
strand intermediates so now we have more
negative strands which are going to be
packaged into new virus particles that's
still in the nucleus in order to get out
of the nucleus you have to put a protein
or proteins on this RNA and in fact
several proteins NEP and m1 are made in
the cytoplasm they're imported they
attach to the RNA and they form the
ribonucleoprotein complex and that can
then be exported these this protein here
any p any p stands for nuclear export
protein that has to be bound to the RNA
in order for it to come out of the
nucleus if that protein isn't present
the RNA would just stay in the nucleus
so now we have our viral rnp
ribonucleoprotein it is the RNA bound
with all the proteins that it would need
in a new infection to initiate infection
it is also has this m1 protein bound to
it that's going to be a structural
protein it goes to the plasma membrane
where the viral glycoproteins are and
the whole structure buds out and forms a
particle this is basically a pinching
off of a membrane segment I believe
we'll look at this a bit later so the
result is viral rnas again we're only
showing two here with all the proteins
they need and the m1 protein which forms
a shell on the inside of the
glycoprotein of the lipid envelope now
the viral a che which is targeted to the
plasma membrane you remember it's one of
these glycoproteins in the particle we
know the structure of the H I remember
it is a fibrous has comprises a fibrous
stem with a globular head the head has
the receptor binding site the receptor
sialic acid fits right in the head here
here's a linear portion or a linear
diagram
of this protein on the bottom so this is
the hemagglutinin a schematic of it it's
embedded in the viral membrane right
here it could be cellular membrane so
you see it has a transmembrane sequence
it has a signal sequence at the
n-terminus that targets it to the ER so
it can get out into the plasma membrane
has a variety of disulfide bonds that
maintain its structure it is has sites
for addition of sugars glycosylation
sites these assistant proper folding of
the protein as it's produced in the
endoplasmic reticulum has the fusion
peptide here remember this is going to
be cleaved eventually right here so the
fusion peptide will be exposed when this
undergoes the low pH shift in the end of
cell so you see a number of signals
which are important for the maturation
of this protein one other site here on
the c-terminus the part of the protein
that's actually either in the cytoplasm
or in the interior of the virion is
actually conjugated with lipids like
palmitate and other similar lipids when
this protein is produced in by ribosomes
bound to the endoplasmic reticulum it
has a signal sequence at the n-terminus
which directs it to the ER lumen the
protein is then threaded into the lumen
the signal sequence is shown here it's
clipped off the protein is threaded into
the lumen it remains bound to the ER
membrane as you can see here and you see
the very c terminus of the protein that
orange bit is lipid it is a particular
lipid that is linked to the protein and
which is important for having this
protein being able to go back and bind
into the membrane and it turns out that
that's very important for assembly and
infectivity of these particles as this
protein moves through the ER and then
the Golgi stacks it becomes it forms
multimers its glycosylated in a variety
of ways you can see here all the
different sugars that are added on as it
passes through in the late golgi it is
cleaved by proteases so that gives you
an active protein and then eventually
will be shipped out via
goes to the plasma membrane so this is a
typical path for a membrane-bound
glycoprotein this is another example of
the maturation of a envelope virus this
is a retrovirus and i want to show you
this because there's a different step
that happens here which is illustrative
retro viral rnas are produced in the
nucleus remember they are produced by
transcription of that proviral DNA copy
which sits in chromosomal DNA so here is
a retro viral mrna coming out of the
nucleus the RNA genome so it's an mRNA
or the RNA genome it becomes bound with
a number of proteins that are produced
as a precursor and then cleaved here is
a schematic of the gag precursor protein
remember these viruses and called a gag
protein which is a structural precursor
a pawl protein which is the reverse
transcriptase are an ACH integrase and
an envelope which is the glycoprotein so
this is just the gag portion and this
contains a number of individual proteins
you can see here they're all released by
processing by a viral protein ace so
these are these are all produced by
translation they fold into a
characteristic structure and some of
them associate with the viral RNA now
here and white is NC nucleocapsid this
is a protein that binds specifically to
the viral RNA you can see here it is
binding the RNA and eventually will
direct the RNA to the membrane another
part of this precursor is matrix ma in
blue matrix targets these proteins to
the plasma membrane we'll see how that
happens in a moment so all these
proteins are together and they're
serving different functions NC is
binding RNA matrix is bringing the whole
thing to the membrane CA is the capsid
protein this will eventually form the
shell around the genome and that's the
brown one so those are all brought in to
this budding structure so here you can
see rnase bound to and see we have a
molecule of capsid which is brown
then the blue ones are the matrix well
here the matrix targets it's a membrane
they form this nice array at the
membrane and member sequential assembly
at the membrane this is helping to
concentrate these components this whole
thing begins to butt out of course the
glycoproteins have already been shipped
up to the plasma membrane these are
encoded by the envelope gene and they're
right here so now we're forming a
particle by budding this if this were
influenza virus this particle would be
done but it's not this is a retrovirus
this particles not finished there is a
protease in here which after the budding
occurs acts to cleave viral proteins and
matures the capsid you can see this is
the final mature capsid the brown
protein is capsid protein this forms an
icosahedral shell and that only
assembles in its final form after the
virus has butted off so it's an example
of a virus that matures after it's
released from the cell okay and that's
why in one of those first slides we had
at the bottom of that scheme maturation
after the virus was released from the
cell yes
okay the difference between NC and ma
and C is nucleocapsid this binds the RNA
specifically matrix is associated with
NC and capsid that's the blue protein
but matrix doesn't buy itself buying the
RNA it interacts with these other
proteins the matrix is has affinity for
the membrane that's what brings the the
complex up to the plasma membrane okay
alright so this is a schematic of the
envelope like a protein of two different
retroviruses it's basically very similar
to the influenza virus HIV the trans
membrane glycoproteins we have
glycosylation sites there are cleavage
sites those big triangles or cleavage
sites because you have to have an
n-terminal fusion protein but remember
you want to keep it buried near the
viral membrane until it's ready to fuse
and then at the n-terminus you have a
signal sequence the protein looks sort
of like this in the final version in the
virus the cleavage separates it into two
pieces called TM four transmembrane that
remains attached to the membrane and su
for surface they are held together by a
disulfide bond so they do stay together
and the su portion will eventually bind
the receptor and remember that receptor
binding will help expose the fusion
peptide which is buried so you see why
you have to cleave this otherwise the
n-terminal would the n-terminus sorry if
you didn't cleave it the fusion peptide
would not be accessible now many viral
proteins are modified with lipids we saw
one example with influenza virus where
the c-terminus of the h.a was modified
by a lipid I think it's palmitate but
I'm not sure and that helps direct the
c-terminus to embed in the membrane
which is apparently important these are
just examples of some other lipids that
can be included you don't have to learn
any of these you don't have to learn the
structure you don't even have to know
the individual names you just need to
know that some viral proteins can be
modified with lipids and they have
specific functions so here's the
modification with myristate myristate on
the first amino acid of a protein and
here is the modification with farnesyl
and other this allows you to target
proteins to various membranes without
having a signal sequence so remember a
signal sequence targets a protein to the
to the secretory pathway makes the
protein go into the ER and eventually
move up the plasma membrane maybe you
don't want to go in that pathway well
you put a lipid in like one of these and
it can target it to other membranes so
in this case you can make the protein in
the cytoplasm and then put the lipid on
and we'll go wherever the lipid is
telling it to go so it doesn't have to
enter that secretory pathway so these
are two of the lipids that are acid
there's some others geraniol geranyl or
palmitate are other lipids that can be
added to viral proteins so here's an
example of modification of a viral
protein with lipid here is the gag
protein of a retrovirus matrix capsid
nucleo capsid proteins which we've
talked about the matrix protein at its
n-terminus is modified with Marissa Tate
or myristic acid it's a fatty acid so
that is right the n terminus of the
protein and here's a expanded view of
that protein right here if you change
this sequence at which murray state is
attached you block the ability of this
protein to associate with the
cytoplasmic face of the plasma membrane
so remember I told you that the matrix
protein of these retroviruses targets
the growing sub assembly to the plasma
membrane the reason it does so is
because it has myristic acid and its
n-terminus and that allows it to go to
the plasma membrane and if you mutate
the sequence so the myristic cannot be
attached which is easy to do you block
assembly and budding so this is totally
essential for assembly and budding
because it directs the matrix protein to
the plasma membrane okay
here we have some other information
about rna-binding I told you that NC is
the nucleocapsid protein which finds RNA
and it does so because it has specific
sequences that interact with RNA okay so
those are just some principles about
targeting of proteins for budding
viruses all viruses of course have to
get genomes into the capsid and they do
that in a variety of ways this is called
genome packaging we call about packaging
a gene on inside the capsid the key
point here is that you have to just
package viral genomes you don't want to
package cellular genomes that would be a
waste of an ice caps it because you
can't do anything with that cellular
genome so you have to be able to
distinguish cellular DNA RNA from the
viral RNA and these of course are all
nucleic acid molecules so you have to
have a specific way of distinguishing
the viral from the cellular molecules
and here's an example of the level of
distinguishing that occurs retro virus
genomes mRNAs are less than 1 percent of
the total RNA in the cytoplasm of a cell
yet every pretty much everything that's
packaged into particles is viral RNA so
there's not a lot of viral RNA in the
cytoplasm it's somehow the budding
machinery can find that viral RNA in a
sea of cellular mRNAs so that's the that
derives from very specific mechanisms
and these are called packaging signals
there are sequences in the genome that
are needed for incorporation of the
nucleic acid into particles and usually
you find these genetically you mutate
parts of the genome until the genome is
not packaged or you take what you think
is a packaging sequence and put it on a
totally different nucleic acid and show
that that other nucleic acid can be
packaged and as a result the number of
these have been identified in various
viruses so let's go through some of
those and figure out how they work here
Packaging sequences from to viral DNA
genomes at the top add no virus type 5
here is the left end of the genome and
we have the e1 a region right here this
is a promoter and read shown here just
for reference this is one of the
inverted terminal repeats of the genome
so that's the left end of the genome and
these blue arrows are all packaging
sequences these are sequences that are
essential for packaging of this DNA into
the ad no virus capsid somehow they are
recognized in the assembly process and
allow the genome to be specifically
packaged and not by a nut cellular DNA
for example you can take this piece of
DNA and put it on another piece of DNA
and that will get into the capsid so
there are multiple packaging sequences
here below is sv40 the double-stranded
DNA genome which we talked about in
terms of not only DNA replication but
RNA synthesis and you can see a lot of
the features here what we referred to in
other lectures the enhancer the sp1
binding sites the origin of replication
in the early transcription unit and
embedded within them is the packaging
signal so you can see the packaging
signal comprises this area from here to
here it overlaps with the enhancer and
the Ori in the sp1 site so this is
typical of these smaller viruses where
you have overlaps of function so again
this is a sequence needed for
incorporation of this viral DNA into the
caption if you take it away if you
mutate it it's just a small piece as you
can see here if you take it away the
viral DNA will not be incorporated so
here's one model for how the herpes
virus genome is packaged the herpes
virus all genome also has packaging
sequence remember this is a
double-stranded DNA it's shown at the
top and here's an expansion of the left
end below it and these sequences the
direct repeats the dr one and two in the
pack one in the pack to these are all
sequences involved in packaging of the
viral DNA
and two caps it remember herpes virus
capsids are assembled with the with the
scaffold inside then the scaffold is
digested away by a viral protease and
then the viral genome is put in through
the portal so there's an opening at 15
fold axis where the viral genome goes in
the genome replication produces concat
immers with head to tail copies of the
genome so you have head to tail then
another one head to tail head to tail
all linked together they're just long
copies of the genome and what happens is
these are recognized by a complex of
proteins including the portal so these
packaging sequences here the pack 1 and
the pack 2 they're all there over here
in this figure in the upper right they
are recognized by the portal as well as
some other viral proteins and then the
DNA is is threaded into the capsid at
the portal portal actually actively
pulls the DNA in so that won't happen
unless there's the there are these
packaging sequences at the left end of
the genome because they have to be
recognized by this set of proteins so
the portal pulls in the genome until it
reaches another set of packaging
sequences so you can see here on this
concatenate here's another you have
multiple multiple copies of this
packaging sequence so the DNA is pulled
in until the second set of packaging
sequences is encountered the specific
sequences are recognized by the portal
and associated proteins the DNA is then
cleaved and that gives you a single unit
of viral DNA in the capsid ok so the
portal and associated proteins recognize
the packaging single they pull in a
single unit of DNA defined by the next
packaging sequence that they encounter
and also until the head is filled up so
there's a certain size of DNA that can
fit in the head when the head is full
and the second packaging sequence is
encountered the DNA is clipped and now
you have a material full of DNA again
hit the packaging sequences are
important for that
how about RNA genomes how does this work
similar ideas you have specific
sequences that are needed for packaging
this is a retrovirus packaging sequence
let's start with the upper right here
this is the left-hand end of to retro
viral genomes a an avian leukosis virus
genome of bird retrovirus and a mouse
retro virus genome so here's an M here's
a full-length mRNA this could be a
genome mRNA there's a packaging sequence
right here thus I symbol that allows the
full-length genome to be packaged the
other if you remember the envelope
protein cannot be translated from the
full-length mRNA what has to happen is
that you have a splice to remove this
sequence in the middle so then you have
the n-terminal piece joined to the
envelope and that can then be translated
so the splicing event removes this
packaging sequence so envelope messenger
rnas are not packaged only the
full-length mRNA is packaged because
they have that size sequence ok for this
virus the size sequence is upstream of
the splice site so that is actually
present in both full-length RNAs and
envelope rnase but only the full-length
is packaged so there's something else
going on here that we don't understand
so this is necessary for packaging but
apparently why the envelope is excluded
we don't understand so that's a very
specific sigh or packaging signal that
directs packaging of full-length rnas
what does that look like here is the
size sequence from hiv-1 and here we are
at the left-hand end of the genome here
is the size sequence right here you can
see it's about a hundred nucleotides
long and it's extensively folded this is
necessary for packaging of HIV RNA
although by itself it's not enough other
sequences are needed so if you took this
sequence
it into another RNA wouldn't that would
not get packaged into HIV particles but
if you take this maloney sigh sequence
and put it into a different RNA that
will be packaged so this is necessary
and sufficient this is necessary but not
sufficient so this is an extensively
folded sequence as you can see and what
we think happens is that two of them
interact to form what's called a kissing
loop complex so these are the these are
the individual loop here SL one of the
two packaging sequences these red areas
are believed to base pair and that base
paired structure is then the substrate
for packaging so the individual RNAs
cannot be packaged only two of them
remember the retro viral RNA is actually
two pieces in the capsid and so this
brings the two genomes together and that
is recognized as being package' below
here's another way to look at that
here's one RNA genome and this is the
packaging sequence shown right here if
you put two of them together you get
dimeric RNA vs or forming these kissing
interactions hear this now produces
binding sites for the viral nucleocapsid
protein and c and that allows the viral
RNA to be incorporated into virions all
right so the packaging signal is
essential for binding of NC which in
turn is needed for packaging but you can
only get this NC binding site expressed
if you have to viral rnas making this
kissing interaction via the packaging
sequence so two examples of how an RNA
sequence could direct packaging another
consideration for packaging is that
there is what's called a packaging limit
there is typically a limit on the size
of nucleic acid that you can put into
especially an icosahedral capsid
remember icosahedron have fixed internal
volumes so there is a little space in
the inmost capsids for putting extra
sequences but it's not limit unlimited
because
captions cannot expand so you typically
have a five or ten percent extra that
you can put in so with these icosahedral
viruses if you want to put jeans in
virgina p you really need to take out
some sequence because you can't fit
enough in for up for a gene so that's
one thing packaging lipids some viruses
like polio we have never been able to
find a packaging signal no one has ever
been able to do that so we don't know
why these viruses always have just viral
RNA in them not cellular RNA one idea is
that the packaging occurs on these
membrane vesicles which is where RNA
replication occurs if you remember from
our talking about RNA synthesis the
viral RNA polymerase is on a vesicle and
it's very concentrated there and it
could be that that is where packaging
occurs because there's no other RNA
present on that vesicle so that may be
where the specificity comes from from
being on a vesicle so there are a number
of viruses for which we don't have such
signals and that may explain the
packaging how about segmented RNA
genomes this is a special problem
because if you have a virus with eight
or ten or twelve pieces how do you make
sure that the virions get one of each
and not to of one and three of another
it wouldn't be infectious okay one copy
of each segment it's an interesting
problem so there are two mechanisms that
have been proposed as a random mechanism
and a selective mechanism so random
means that the virus just grabs eight
segments at one time it doesn't matter
and eventually you'll get one virus in
so many that's infectious right and and
selective means there's a binding site
on the segment for specific genome
segments so if you did a random
mechanism with influenza virus which has
eight segments you would get one
infectious particle out of every four
hundred assembled so basically 399 would
be garbage because they would have they
would be missing a segment or two or
more and one would be infectious and
that is actually close to the known
particle the pfu ratio of the virus
remember particle the pfu ratio you look
at all the part
because of a virus and you asked which
ones are infectious for fluids about one
and four hundred so it could be that
there's a random mechanism going on here
but if 12 segments are packaged ten
percent of the particles would contain a
complete genome so you could put a lot
of pack segments in and you could get
even more infectivity than one in four
hundred we don't know if this actually
occurs or not more recently there
there's some evidence that there are
specific sequences on each RNA segment
that says put this one into the capsid
put RNA one two three and four and not
ten of RNA one or eight of RNA one
specific sequences so if you if you take
a cross-section of virions that are
maturing from cells this is what you see
and the point here is that you can see
the viral rnas are very in a very
regular pattern here so they're all they
all look like they're standing up top to
bottom as shown in this model right here
okay so you see the one two three four
five six eventually there are eight rnas
you can't see them all in this section
but they seem to be very ordered in the
particle so the model has arisen is that
at the ends of each RNA there are
specific sequences that and interact
with the viral proteins as this particle
is budding and they put each RNA in a
very specific place in the capsid and
each RNA has a signal that directs it to
the particle you can't have more than
one of each segment in the particle as a
consequence so there's some genetic and
here physical evidence that that's the
case there is an example of selective
packaging in back in a bacteriophage
it's called fee 6 it has three double
stranded RNA segments all right they're
called sm + l now this is very neat the
s goes in first into the capsid you
can't do anything else until you have s
in there then M comes in but only a fast
is present and then finally L requires
the present of S Plus app so this is a
selective packaging mechanism
is only one way you can put the RNAs in
s el Sr es mal if you don't have s you
don't start the process so this you
would predict from this that every
particle is infectious and in fact the
particle the P of you ratio this virus
is one so it does a good job of making
infectious particles and it seems to be
because of this serial dependence of
packaging okay finally let's talk about
how viruses get envelopes sometimes this
happens after internal structures are
assembled as with influenza virus and
we'll talk about that or it may happen
as internal structures assemble these
are four separate strategies for
acquiring an envelope this could be any
membrane here we have a situation where
the envelope glycoproteins and the
capsid are both essential for budding so
you have to express both the capsid
which is shown in yellow here and the
glycoproteins then you get a particle so
that's one here we have an example where
the internal proteins drive budding so
either the matrix protein the MA or the
gag protein of retroviruses will on
their own Drive budding you don't need
to have any glycoproteins present here
we have envelope proteins driving
budding flu is an example of that you
can express just the h.a and get
breading and then finally a more complex
scenario where the matrix protein will
drive budding but you need additional
proteins such as the glycoproteins in
the RNA even for addition for efficiency
and accuracy so these are the ways that
envelope virus is mature at various
membranes and the kinds of proteins that
are needed to do each step we looked at
this already for for influenza virus how
sub-assemblies are made we make the RNA
assembly we put the plasma membrane
teens up and that buds off to font to
form a particle and again with influenza
you could drive this budding just by the
synthesis of H a in cells but in fact in
an infected cell there is sufficient rnp
that the particles that come off contain
viral genomes the influenza virus m1
just like the matrix protein of the
retroviruses is targeted to the plasma
membrane by hydrophobic regions so
there's an n-terminal hydrophobic region
on the m1 protein there are also regions
that bind the RNA so remember here's the
m1 protein bound to the RNA and then the
m1 is going to target the plasma
membrane so what brings it there are
these hydrophobic sequences on the
n-terminus and of course the RNA is
bound here same goes for vesicular
stomatitis virus m protein which is also
a sub membrane protein you have n
terminal hydrophobic regions sorry we
have n-terminal charged reasons that
bind to the RNA and in a more internal
hydrophobic region for membrane binding
so another way of explaining how we
target these sub assemblies to the
budding complex so that's why we don't
get just empty particles made you would
think while you're making a che why
don't we just butt off empty particles
because this association of the rnp is
very efficient and the same goes for
retroviruses we discussed this already
but I want to make the point is that if
you just synthesize the gag protein
alone this is sufficient to make virus
particles but when you do have RNA
present the RNA efficiently associates
with the gag protein via that NC protein
and so that the virus particles that are
made contain the genome if you just make
gag by itself you will get particles but
when RNA is present those are
selectively incorporated to the
particles now a very interesting
understanding of the budding process
came about five or six years ago when I
mean certain amino acid changes in the
gag protein remember
structural precursor were shown to cause
a budding arrest at a late stage so
these are examples of mutations that the
virus would start to bud and then it
would arrest at this stage so here's an
example of that over here and here so
the virions are on the surface they're
almost fully matured but they're stuck
by this stalk and they never come off
and this is because they have amino acid
changes in the gag protein and these
regions that accommodated these changes
were called late domains because they
had a late effect in virus maturation
these have subsequently been found in
many plus and minus strand RNA viruses
and the idea is these domains defined by
these mutations the L domains they bind
cell proteins that are involved in
vesicle trafficking so you know the the
entry of vesicles into cells by
endocytosis the exit of vesicles to
secrete material that trafficking is all
mediated by a very involved cellular
system which involves a variety of
proteins and viruses have tacked on to
that system by interacting with those
proteins via these L domain containing
proteins to get their viewer yawns but
it out and this was discovered by
mutating these proteins and finding this
phenotype and these are just examples of
these l domains so again these are
domains in viral proteins if you change
them you block the budding of viruses so
for example retroviruses these are all
different retroviruses here that infect
different species they have L domains of
different kinds of oval shaped ones and
diamond shaped ones and shaded ones
they're all over the protein ebola and
marburg viruses have L domains and in
their viral protein so to rabies viruses
and arena viruses and they're different
sequences here you can see the motifs
prolene threonine serine alanine
pralines etc so there are three
different kinds of L domains so again if
you mutate one of these amino acids in
this L domain you arrest budding at a
late stage that's the definition of an
elderly these L domains interact with
cell proteins that are involved in
vesicle trafficking so the trafficking
of vesicles in cells has been dissected
exquisitely in both yeast and in
mammalian cells and these are some of
the protein complexes that are important
for vesicle budding out of cells and for
vesicles coming into cells by
endocytosis and these are the way the l
domains interact with these proteins
these PTA p lxx LF L P P XY these are
viral L domain sequences and they
specifically interact with these
cellular proteins that are involved in
vesicle budding so the virus in order to
bud has latched on to these proteins and
this helps pull them out of the cell so
in in normal cells uninfected cells this
is called the escort machinery by the
way that cell protein machineries here
that helped direct vesicle traffic in
and out of the cell there are three
different kinds of membrane abscission
that are all related that involved this
pathway so normally in cells taking up
vesicles from the surface here we have a
vesicle at the plasma membrane
invaginate and coming into the cell and
these the formation of these vesicles
requires this escort protein pathway
when cells divide here are two cells
about to divide this middle section here
has to break it's sort of like when a
virus buds from the cell surface the to
the bud has to pinch you off well when
cells divide this has to pinch off as
well these escort proteins are involved
in that as well and here we have virus
budding from the cell and the escort
pathway the proteins are also involved
in that as well so the mechanisms are
yet to be elucidated but just starting
with mutations in these viral
glycoproteins identify their interaction
with this machinery that's needed for
vesicle traffic so this is how viruses
bud from cells by latching on to this
escort pathway very interesting now
where do virus
but I told you a couple of examples of
budding from the plasma membrane but
they can virtually bud from any membrane
in the cell herpes buds through the
nuclear membrane coronaviruses blood
into the ER bunya viruses but into the
Golgi so called ger plasma membrane
nuclear membrane viruses will some virus
will but into at least one of them
here's an example of herpes virus
budding herpes that you remember are
synthesized in the nucleus capsid is
made in the nucleus at buds through the
nuclear membrane acquires a membrane
doing that that it's got to get out of
the ER so here it is in the ER so it
fuses with the ER membrane here it is
back in the cytoplasm it's naked again
it buds into the trans-golgi picks up a
membrane then buds again and picks up a
second membrane and finally fuses at the
plasma membrane and now you have your
envelope virus ok so a series of budding
and unbuttoned if budding infusion steps
gives you the final envelope virus and
the last one it's got double membrane
here at this point and then it sheds one
to become the extracellular virus so
here is an example of a virus that goes
through cell you several membranes
nuclear ER Golgi and plasma membrane to
make the final virus not all viruses are
this complex and the last step is how do
viruses get out of cells so we've talked
a lot about budding many viruses are
released by budding from the plasma
membrane if they butt into an interior
vesicle they can be taken to the surface
and released by the secretory pathway
other viruses get out by killing the
cell by breaking it open in the cells
lice and then they can move from cell to
cell here's a wonderful picture of the
polarized release of HIV from an
infected t-cell HIV buds from the plasma
membrane and here's an infected t-cell
here and all the very odds are being
released that one end of the t-cell so
it's not they're not being released all
over the plasma membrane they're
released at one side that's why we call
it polarized release so that's one way
that viruses get out of cells they can
be released
from the cells the apical domain of
cells remember most cells in your body
or polarized so you can be released from
apical domains you can spread laterally
and some viruses do both and you can
also be released from the basolateral
domain which isn't shown here so if the
virus was released from the apical
surface if this were your lung it would
help the virus to spread by sneezing and
we'll talk about that subsequently so
apical surface release places the virus
in the outside world if you are released
from the basal side it puts the virus in
contact with your circulation so it can
spread in your body and infect other
tissues and that's not good and this can
it happen wherever cells are infected
this will influence pathogenesis
wherever the virus is released the
direction and the mode has enormous
consequences on the pathogenesis which
we will talk about in subsequent
lectures some cells actually break open
and release viruses the bacteriophages
of course are often lytic in the lice
bacteria because they encode specific
proteins that break the bacteria open
some viruses do the same they break
their infected cells open that's the
process called lysis but we really don't
we have really not identified specific
viral proteins that do that as opposed
to the bacteriophage proteins that do it
we think that many viruses by inhibiting
macromolecular processes and transport
help to kill the cell in this way many
viruses induce apoptosis programmed cell
death and that causes lysis as well
there are some specific mechanisms there
is a protease produced by ad no virus
which cleaves intermediate filament
proteins of the cell this probably
contributes to cell lysis and
facilitates virus release there's also a
glycoprotein that is essential for lysis
of cells by adna virus if you take this
glycoprotein away genetically the virus
does not lie cells although we don't
know how this works finally I want to
share with you a way that some lytic
viruses may get out of cells
non lytic way so polio is your
quintessential lytic virus it replicates
in cells and pulverizes them in 8 hours
they fragment and the virus particles
are released but in a fraction of cells
very early on you can detect viruses
being released in the absence of cell
killing and that is because when polio
infect cells it induces a cellular
response called autophagy Toa G is a
response to stress whereby the cell
begins to capture its cytoplasm in these
vesicles so a vesicle derived from the
ER forms and surrounds the cytosolic
contents eventually these vesicles fuse
with lysosomes and then go to the cell
surface and release the contents a way
of recycling the cell if you will so
that the contents can be used what
poliovirus does it induces autophagy
where the cell responds by vannan
response to an infection by inducing
autophagy the virus uses these vesicles
to replicate its genomes and in the
process of formation of these vesicles
some virions are captured inside of them
late in infection and these eventually
go to the surface and release the
particles in a non lytic manner so the
amount the extent to which this
contributes to release is probably
minimal but could be that in cell
certain cells where lysis doesn't occur
this is a contributing factor so viruses
can life cells to release particles they
can release particles by budding in
various and these both can occur at
various parts of the cell and where it
does has consequences for pathogenesis
and they're also our non lytic
mechanisms of release for viruses like
polio sv40 which we normally believe to
lie cells the last example is a
fascinating virus isolated from a hot
spring in Italy which is not only 85 to
95 85 to 93 degrees in temperature but
it's page one and a half
there are places in the world like there
is a are key a bacteria acid aeneus
convivial are key a and this is a
bacteriophage now not bacteriophage this
is a virus that infects this archaea
because our key a are not bacterial so
this this virus looks like this if you
grow it in cell culture this is what it
looks like it has two tails this is the
mature virus is the this is the nucleic
acid here and as two tails on either
side if you do an infection of this our
key a in the lab at 90 degrees the virus
that's produced from the cell looks like
this ok it's not mature so these are
released from the arc EA in this form if
you let the particle sit in the medium
at 90 degrees for an hour or so they
begin to mature into the final particle
so this is all happening extracellular
Lee it goes from this lemon shaped
particle to this one with the two tails
so everything is in there to complete
this maturation there's no more cell
this is happening extracellular Lee so
this is a brand new discovery how
widespread it is we don't know but it's
very interesting because this all
happens outside of the cell
you